If we are serious about preventing climate
change, we need to be pumping a lot less of
this into the atmosphere.
That is the message in a new UN report.
Its authors warn of a growing "Emissions Gap"
between rising emissions and the reductions
needed to achieve the goals set out in the
Paris Climate accords.
Worldwide emissions have to be cut by a quarter
by 2030 to keep global warming at 2 degrees
Celsius above pre-industrial levels, and avoid
drastic consequences, says the report.
And the biggest elephant in the room that
we refuse to see is the risk that it poses
to everything we like and appreciate in this
planet.
Whether bio-diversity is your thing or sustainable
finance or the health of the planet, or people
or prosperity or peace, human movements...
you just pick up anything you like, everything
is at risk.
At a UN summit in the Polish mining town of
Katowice starting Sunday, delegates will hammer
out a plan to meet the Paris accords, a task
which seems much harder than
they
first imagined.